you have two kids i have one one
daughter one daughter twenty three okay
boom this is perfect so
your advice to yeah exactly i mean yeah
no no this is just hopefully
i've said this before 23 year old
daughter she's at the quote unquote
prime of her life right now people i'm
sure you know if she you're her dad and
a hot mom she's looking all right what
are you telling her you're saying hey
listen babe you've got a few years to
capitalize on this i want you go to
school i want you to be successful but
not too successful and here's what i
want you to do what what are you telling
your daughter well my daughter's already
a girly girl to begin with okay she's a
pageant girl by the way she knew uh
what's the black girl who just committed
suicide the the pageant winner girl who
i uh chris uh i forget to know chelsea
christ i think is what her name is
which is very tragic tragic this just
happened yeah it just sounds yeah um and
so uh but she's she's very she's very
feminine she's naturally feminine um she
is she's got a good head on her shoulder
she's doing post-graduate work um i
won't tell you what
what college is on publicly but um she's
just finishing up her post-grad um she
has a boyfriend who is very much alpha
guy a hockey player okay um and so older
yes yes yes and she um she naturally i
think gravitates towards guys who are i
would say follow a certain template or a
certain model um and yes to to be honest
with you i've said the same thing i said
you know you are at the prime of your
life you're at the peak where you're
your selection you're you're you're
you're what does she tell you agency is
that well see that's the problem
this is my daughter this is royal
tomasi's daughter okay so this is kind
of like i'm biased here she's going to
be biased because she's getting this
from me but um of course like the
the problem that most women have with
what i have to say when they have a
problem with it is they tend to conflate
sexual market value with their personal
worth and that's i think remember you're
asking me what advice would you give to
women i would say look there's a
difference between your sexual market
value and your personal value so when
women say well look i've got a career i
have a my own business i have all this
stuff i did everything that i was told
to do by the books i'm a a powerful
alpha female and um
and i you know still can't find a man
but this is where i'm at how dare you
tell me that uh that i'm not hot or i'm
not attractive and the problem that i
have is that when you conflate sexual
market value with your personal worth
your personal worth becomes what you
think should be attractive or what men
should find attractive in you men are
not necessarily looking for a woman who
is a high-powered ceo or an attorney or
whatever they're looking for a girl
who's like good-looking feminine and
sexually available and they want to get
with that and anything beyond that point
once you've established that
relationship that's all gravy after that
point but they're not looking for a guy
they're not men generally heterosexual
men are not looking for another guy to
marry they're looking for a woman to
marry because that's the complimentary
nature between men and women you're not
you're not even talking about
homosexuality you're not you're talking
about
another woman oh we can we can we can
talk about homosexuality no no but in
this context you're talking about they
don't want to marry a
woman who is trying to be a man like
that's what you're exactly yeah they're
looking for the yin and the yang right i
mean they're like i've said this before
like people will throw rocks at me so
let me be clear right now
from my perspective men and women are
innate natural evolved compliments to
one another my strengths as a man
complement my wife's weaknesses as a
woman and vice versa we are better
together than we are apart and the
problem is as you were saying before so
we have this separation why aren't
people getting married why aren't we
forming these monogamous you know
families why you talked to jordan
peterson a little while ago was a uh
socially enforced monogamy why is that a
thing in the past all of a sudden it's
because men or women literally have no
use for men
except for a few top-tier guys that
they're
being whether by force or by choice are
being forced or choice to uh to choose
that one guy and share that one guy so
when we talk about high-powered guys and
having you know why would that guy who
has at the peak of his sexual
selectivity maybe he's 37 years old 36
or seven years old he's on top of his
game he's he's hitting his stride he's
made his first millions he's got his own
business he's got he's the success story
of manhood why is he going to want to
get with a woman who is like his equal
who or that he would perceive as his
equal and not get with a lot of hot
girls like dan bilzerian or something
like that or get with with a lot of
women at one time you have that sexual
selectivity and then choose from among
them who he wants to have children with
and who are you
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]